Ben bu hayatta Bana en büyük dersi bir
sincabın vereceğini asla düşünemezsin
Bundan 20 yıl kadar önce bir hikaye
duydum ve gün bir sincap evinden ayrılıp
yan Bahçede bir keşfe çıkmak istemiş
dolaşmış dolaşmış Bir bakmış ki etrafı
çitlerle çevrili hiçbir şekilde içeriye
girmesinin mümkün olmayacağı bir alana
gelmiş bir kere daha dolaşınca bakmış ki
Orada küçük bir delik orada Acaba
buradan içeriye bu bahçeye girebilir
miyim diye düşünmeye başlamış fakat
bakmış gibi dene oraya sığmayacak şöyle
bir çözüm bulmuş Üç gün boyunca oruç
tutmuş ve güzel zayıflamış biraz daha
zayıflamış bir gün daha oruç tut
ve en sonunda o küçük delikten süzülerek
O bahçeye girivermiş içerde asma
yaprakları üzümler meyveler harika
yiyecekler demiş ki bunların hepsinden
tatmak istiyorum teker teker Hatta evine
dönmeyi bile düşünmemiş birkaç gün orada
kalmaya karar vermiş fakat bütün o
meyveleri tükettikten yedikten sonra
biraz Reha Bey çökmüş dinleneyim demiş
ama eve dönüş Vakti de yaklaşmaya
başlamış ve demiş ki artık Tamam buradan
çıkmam gerek kadar kilo almış O
kadar sen izlenmiş ve şişmanlamış ki o
zaten oruç tutarak içeriye girdiği
delikten bir daha dışarıya çıkamamış
ve tekrar oruç tutmam gerektiği karar
vermiş üç gün üç gece tekrar oruç tutmuş
eski haline gelmeye çalışmış zayıflamış
ekstra bir gün daha tutmuş Tıpkı başta
yaptığı gibi Ve sonunda dışarıya
süzülerek zar zor çıktıktan sonra bir
tane ağaç olma seslenmiş ne yaptın
içeride Vallahi yaptığım şeyler hiçbir
şey anlamadım oruç tuttum içeriye girdim
oradan hiçbir şey götüremedim dışarıya
ve yine tekrar aynı sıkıntıyı çekerek
oruç tuttum ve dışarıya çıktım söyle
bana ağaç ben ne anladım bu işten ağaç
söyle cevap vermiş dünya hayatı da buna
benzer bu dünyaya gelirsin bir takım
deneyimler yaşarsın buradaki öğretiler
meyveler yediklerin içtiklerin hepsi
orada kalır ve dışarıya çıktığında
sadece Zihnine kasığın dene
Ben onlarla dışarıya çıkarsın bu
sincaptan çok şey öğrendim dünya hayatı
Gerçekten bunun gibi bir şey yaşadıkça
Aslında hepimiz bunu anlamıyor muyuz
burada bir şeyler yaşanıyor zorluklar
çekiliyor acılara göğüs giriyoruz kadın
veya erkek olmamızın değil güçlü ayakta
olmamızın beklendiği bir dünyaya
doğduğumuzu görüyoruz birtakım bazı
beceriler bize yükleniyor aynı
bilgisayar programları gibi Kimimiz
müziğe sanata resme edebiyata sinemaya
bambaşka bir şeylere de eğilim sahibi
olarak Buraya gelebiliyor bazen de orada
bu geceleri kazanıyoruz Dünyada hayat
bize bir şeyler öğretiyor bazen elimiz
yanıyor bazen canımız yanıyor bazen bir
şeylerden vazgeçmemiz gerekiyor
birşeyleri mutlaka kaybediyoruz
birşeyleri kazanabilmek için o yüzden
sincabı asla unutmuyorum bu hikaye size
bu için anlattım ne zaman ben ne anladım
bu işten niye buradayım niçin bunları
yaşamak zorunda kaldım dediğimiz zaman
her zaman o sincabı hatırlayalım Evet
dünya hayatı Aynen böyle birşey burada
yaşadıklarımız edindiğimiz bütün
tecrübeler ver nasıl ki nereden
geldiğimizi bilmiyorsak gibi Afrin
olarak Sonuçta bir annenin bedenini
kullanıyoruz O kapsülde bir süreç
geçiyor Daha sonra dünyaya fırlatıyoruz
Şartlar ne olursa olsun yaşamamız hayata
uyum sağlaması ve aynı sincap gibi bir
şekilde oradaki öğretileri alıp işimize
gelenleri depolayıp işimize yaramayan
larıda atmamızı bu öğreniyoruz bunu bize
Hayat bir şekilde öğretiyor Kimisi için
erken olan Kimisi için geç olabiliyor
sanırım o yüzden zaman Göreceli bir
kavram
Ama bazı şeyler benim için çok Sarsıcı
olabilirken bir başkası onu zaten Aylar
yıllar önce hatmetmiş hatta o acılarla
olgunlaşmış olabiliyor güzellikte
zamanda göreceli kavramlar hepimizin
beynine kodlanmış olan bir takım doğru
diyemeyeceğim ama yanlış da
diyemeyeceğim olgular var Sonra düşün
dedim ki acaba bu dünyaya gelişiyle
ilgili kendime ait bir felsefem olsaydı
bunu ne benzetirdim ve bunu bir valize
benzet Evet hepimiz dünyaya gelmeden
önce yükünün ne olduğu belli olmayan
kaldırmayın ca anlayamayacağımız
ağırlığı olan valizlerle buraya
geliyoruz dedim Peki bu Valizin içinde
neler var Madem nereden geldiğimiz tam
olarak belli değil hepimiz birtakım
düşünceler içindeyiz işte bir bir
Yaradana ait Işık pıhtıları yız buraya
bir takım olay
her şeyim demek için geldik tek bir
ortak nokta var o da Buraya gelen bir
şekilde buradan ayrılıyor ve bir daha
geri gelmiyor bu hepimizin bildiği bir
gerçek O zaman dünya yaşamını aslında
bir yolculuğa da benzetebilir yoruz o
zaman bu varis felsefesi içinde neyin
olup olmadığıyla ilgili değil Acaba bu
yükü ne kadar taşıyabilirim ile ilgili
olabilir mi diye bir takım düşünceler
içine girdim şimdi Dışarıdan
bakıldığında kimin valizinin ağır kimin
valizinin hafif olduğunu ancak
kaldırınca anlayabiliyor Sak Demek ki
herkesin kendi yükü kendine göre ağır
şöyle bir noktadan Daha beslendiğim
aslında Çin Hepimiz böyle avm'lere
gidiyoruz işte alışveriş merkezleri
diyoruz Fakat ben Zehra Lara gittiğini
gördüm Akşamları herkes 1wm aya gidiyor
valiz muhafaza al
çok uyku dan önce yüklerinizi bir
şekilde bırakmak zorundayız Yoksa bütün
bunlarla yorulmuş bir şekilde Zaten
beyin uykuya geçemez o zaman herkes
acaba uykuda dışarıda bıraktığı
yüklerini sorumluluklarını açılarını
sırlarını günahlarını mutluluklarını
zaferlerini hepsini bir paket olarak bir
varise muhafaza ediyor hepimizde var
oval istenen kiminin dışı daha şatafatlı
kemiğinin dışı biraz daha da zarar
görmüş gibi görünebilir renkler belki
farklıdır fakat içinde iyi veya kötü bu
hayat yolculuğunda taşıyacağımız yükler
var yük olumsuz gibi birşey gibi
duymuyor olabilir ama yük aslında bizi
biz yapan bütün malzemelerin toplamı
ya Anne olmak eş olmak birey olmak
öğrenci olmak gün geliyor rehber
oluyoruz gün geliyor biri bize rehberlik
yapıyor dünyada daha fazla zaman
geçirmiş olan Dünyada daha az zaman
geçirmiş olana bilgilerini tecrübelerini
aktarıyor ki bu yolculukta bir şekilde
Onun yükünü hafifletmek için yufka
pisletmek ve yükleri üzerinize almak
Aslında tercih diyebiliriz ki
atalarımızdan bize genetik olarak
kodlanmış olan yüklerle Birlikte
geldiğimiz varsayarsak Benim şu tuhaf
anlamsız yükseklik korkum acaba yıllar
önce bunu yaşamış olan bir adamın
geninden Bana geçmiş ise Eğer onu bu
hayatta da taşıyorsam acaba bu yükten bu
hayatta kurtulma imkanı var mı bu bana
ne öğretecek Eğer bir şey vermiyorsa
bana bir katkısı yoksa o yükü bu var
ismi
bu alanı olan ve meada Aslında
bırakabilirim Bazen yüklerinizi
değiştirdiğimizde olur hatta bazen kendi
yüklerinizi başkalarına taşıdığımızda
olur Bazen de gönüllü olarak bir
başkasının yükünü taşımaya ona iş teklif
ederiz Çünkü biz Aslında o valizi
taşımaktan hem gurur duyarız hem onur
duyarız hem de o yükler bize yüklendikçe
Belki de alanımızın daha fazla yük ye
açık bir hale geldiğini de düşünebiliriz
burada hepimizin hayatla ilgili neyi
nasıl anladığını çok önemli olduğunu
düşünüyorum Kimileri yüklerinden
beslenirken kimileride yüklerinden
kurtulma çabasındadır yaşam boyunca da
bu böyle devam ediyor Anladığım
kadarıyla böyle şimdi o zaman şöyle bir
olaya da girebilir miyiz bir tespitin
daha olacak hareler
Sen nasıl böyle insanın cephesinde şöyle
bir hali işareti vardı hatta yeni yeni
dijital dünyada emojiler de görüyoruz
bir tane Emoji var Bayılıyorum ben ona
genelde hep olumlu anlamda kullanılan
bir Hare vardır Böyle gülücük üzerindeki
o Hare onu hiçbir zaman olumsuz bir
olayın altına koymayı yani o kızgın
ifade bellidir Nereye gideceği bir olaya
kızmış hızlı sinirlenmiş izr ama
Tepedeki o hareli Emoji bir şekilde hep
olumlu bir olayı ifade eder sonra
Psikolojinin derinliklerine indiğinde
karşıma söyledi gerçek çıktı harika
etkisi diye bir olgu var Ve bunun tam
zıttı olan korna etkisi şimdi böyle
İngilizce terimler söyleyip Antipatik
olmak istemiyorum ama Halo effect
dediğimiz Hare etkisinin İngilizce
olarak psikoloji terimleri ne
o tarih Bir de horoz efekt dediğimiz
kornat dıt korna ya basıyoruz ve bütün
Hayat bütün bu dünya yolculuğu Aslında
buhar eve korna etkisiyle yürüyor bunu
keşfet bunu paylaşmak istedim Bugün
sizde şimdi insanlarla ilgili markalarla
ilgili kurumlarla ilgili ülkelerle
ilgili ırklarla ilgili İnsanların iç
dünyaları ile ilgili dış görünüşleri ile
ilgili ya ilk izlenimde bir Hare etkisi
var ya da bir korna etkisi var bu çocuğu
işe almayalım baksana biraz hafif
tırnakları elleri hafif bakımsız Büyük
ihtimalle bu bizim işimize de iyi
bakmıyor bilir bazen de şöyle yanılgılar
içinde olabiliyorsunuz bu kişinin giyimi
Gayet düzgün Kendine iyi bak a bildiği
de aşık harf Büyük ihtimalle bu bizim
kızımıza da iyi bakabilir Bu bizim
şirketimizin insan kay
O fatmanı da yönetebilir bizim
apartmanda yönetebilir hiç fark etmez
tamamen korna etkisi ve Hare etkisiyle
bir takım kararlar veriyoruz o valizimi
Zeki yüklerde zaten o etkilerin
tefsiriyle onların artış oklarıyla o
valize ya giriyor ya çıkıyor şimdi bir
düşünelim bakalım acaba ne kadar yanılma
payımız var şimdi bilişsel olarak zihin
kandırılabilir bir orada Ona istediğiniz
bir şey yükleyip İstediğiniz bir şeyi
rahatlıkla çekebiliyorsunuz bunu tarih
boyunca gördük hepimiz şahit olduk ki
düşünsen olarak ürettiğimiz bütün
fikirler düşünceler Hem yıpratılmaya
müsait Hem yüceltilmiş müsait Bu da o
zaman şu sonuca varıyoruz bir kişi ile
ilgili aldığın Hare etkisi Bir
Başkasında korna etkisi yapıyorsa
aradaki farkı ne belir
O benim valizimde ki yükler valizimde
Eğer bu tür bir olaya karşı bu tür bir
olay gelişir gibi matematik varsa bu
matematiği her şeyi uyguluyorum ve bu
benim en çok hata yapma sebebim oluyor
bazen bundan adam olmaz dediğimiz
Çocukların nasıl adam olduklarını
görüyoruz nasıl topluma faydalı
olduklarını görüyoruz o zaman neydi
oradaki korna etkisi Neden bunu düşündük
Konuşurken biraz duraksadı için çekingen
olduğu için duygusal insanların bazen
kendilerini ifade etmekte zorluk çektiği
gibi bir bilgiyi öğrendikten sonra Acaba
hala bunun üzerinde durabilir miyiz
dayanak olarak Demek ki yaşam hem çok
esnek her türlü kırılmaya müsait hem
valizlerin yükünü atabileceğimiz hem de
eğer boş ver varsa var ise yeni
bilgileri koyabileceğimiz bir alan hasta
Çok keyifli çok güzeldi
bu dediğimiz sabit şey ise bir gün sona
erdi nasıl ki geliyoruz bir şekilde
gidiyoruz o zaman biz burada misafir
sake bizden önce bir çok medeniyet
birçok uygarlık birçok düşünce tarzına
sahip ruhu olan bedeni olan aynı zamanda
hatalar yapan bir çok kişi geçti bu
dünyada biz de onlardan birisin Ama Oh
oliser Bizimle her seferinde dünyaya
gelirken bir şekilde yarı dolu ya da
boşluğa olabilir Evet çok tıkış tıkış
olabilir belki burada o yükü azaltacağız
anlamına da gelebilir miyim Ama her şey
devinim içinde sürekli bir şeyler
değişiyor dönüşüyor farklı alanlarda
bize başka pencereler açtıkça da biz
Olgun ulaşıyoruz duyuyoruz Ve sanırım
de aynı o şekilde o bahçede kendini Ben
ne anladım bu işten diyen kişi gibi
bulduğumuz bir anda da şu soruyu
düşünmeliyiz Evet buradan hiçbir şeyi
götüremiyoruz ama bilgimizi
birikimlerimizi ruhumuza kazılı bir
şekilde hafıza dediğimiz o beynin en
arka planında kara kutu gibi hizmet
veren Bizi biz yapan odata Bankası'na
birçok deneyim aktarıyoruz belki de o
atalarımızdan bize atandığını
düşündüğümüz üzerimizde bize korku Neşe
mutluluk ya da Özgüven gibi Herhangi bir
olguyu yükleyen bir şey bizden daha
önceki bir yolculukta valize eklenmiş
olma ihtimalini gözardı edemeyiz O zaman
demek ki yaşam yolculuğu sürekli devam
ediyor
Evet şimdi burada diyeceksiniz acaba
Rengar rasyonda mı bahsediyor acaba İşte
bu bedenlenme vesaire ruhun hafızası
bedenin geçici oldu Evet biraz hepsinden
karışık bahsediyorum Bütün bunlardan ne
anladığınızda da alakalı Şimdi Eğer
düşünürseniz Biz aslında ruhun gerçekten
bir hafızası olduğunu ve ancak bedenle
fizik ve bunu ifade edebildiğini
görüyoruz böyle bir insana bakın
kaldıramıyor sunuz hiçbir şekilde onunla
iletişime geçemiyoruz değişen ne fizik
olarak orada fakat bir şey uçtu gitti
eve gitti Nereden geldin Nereye gitti
ama dünya hayatı hakikatten böyle birşey
burada yaşadığımız deneyimlediği miz
bütün olayları kötü ya da iyi olarak
algılamak yerine gidenin hiçbir zaman
Bak çok kötü bir şeyim ve şu anda sana
geliyorum demiyor bir başkası için
bu itici olan bir başkası için kadar
kırıcı o kadar yakıcı olabiliyor ki bir
daha Valizini bile açmak istemiyor
içinden ne birşey çıkarıyor Ne de içine
birşey ekliyor şimdi hepiniz bir düşün
üç günlük bir yer değil bir aylığına
herhangi bir seyahate çıkmanız
gerekseydi nasıl valiz yapardınız valiz
yapma tekniği mizin Aslında arkamızdan
gelen yüklerin bu hayatta yüklendiği miz
her şeyin ve ileride de gelecekte de bu
dünyada olsak da olmasak da bir başka
yolculukta bize nasıl hizmet edebileceği
bizi nasıl yapabileceği Ya da nasıl
ödüllendirileceği ile ilgili aslında çok
önemli bir alandır dünya yaşam
Bu nasıl polis yapıyorsunuz şimdi
İhtiyacınız olan şeyleri mi Sadece
koyuyorsunuz öncelikleriniz belli mi
Yoksa ya Bu da lazım olursa Bence en
iyisi bunun modelini de alayım bu da
bulunsun Bu da bulunsun diyerek mi yola
çıkıyorsunuz Çoğu kişi genelde o
yolculuktan nasıl döndüğünü test ettiği
anda o yolculuğun amacını öğrenmiş olduk
ancak dönüş anında onu anlayabiliyoruz
üç tane katlanmış dokunulmamış ütüsü
bile bozulmamış gömlekle dönüyor Summer
Demek ki ben fazla önemli olduğum için
bu hayatta bazı şeyleri kaçırıyor
olabilirim ya da bazen tam tersi oluyor
fark etmez nasıl olsa hallederim deyip
bu sefer eksik valiz yapıp sürekli
hayatımızda bir şeylerin yoksunluğunu da
çekebiliyoruz yeteri kadar sevilmemek
yeteri kadar saygı duymamak yeteri kadar
sesimizi duyuramamak yeteri kadar bir
şeyler Es
bu sahip olamamak Acaba nasıl polis
yapıyoruz Bugünden itibaren hepinizin
varis yaparken Gerçekten öncelikleri mi
belirliyor muyum gibi bir soru sorarak
önceki yolculuğunuz şimdi ki mevcut
yolculuğunuz ve bir sonraki
yolculuğunuzda Acaba ne tür hasarlara
sebep veriyoruz ya da ne tür
kazanımlarımız var Belki de diyeceksiniz
ki her zaman tam valiz yaptım O zaman
şunu anlayabiliriz Belki daha önceki
yaşamsal yolculuklarınızda o kadar çok
Bu gelgitleri yaşadığınız ki şu anda
hissettiğiniz huzurun ya da Mutluluk
kırıntısının sebebi sizin valiz yapma
sanatının inceliklerini öğrenmiş olmanız
olabilir Bir de çok şık valizlerin
içinde Karman çorman rastgele koyulmuş
Aslında içinde koyulabilecek çok daha
fazla muhafaza alanı ol abi
çok kötü yerleştirmeden dolayı yanlış
öncelik belirleme den dolayı böyle bir
Valizle sürekli seyahat ediyormuş gibi
de hissedebiliriz Her şey bizim için
problem olabilir Bir de tabii ki ve M A
dediğimiz o alana ne kadar uğruyoruz
tamam uykuda uyku bırakıyoruz doğru
fakat hepinize olmuyor mu uyanmadan
şöyle bir yarım saat kadar önce bütün
hepsi birden aklımıza gelmeye başlıyor
çözmemiz gerekenler bizi rahatsız eden
olaylar bazen intikam hisleriyle dolu
taşıyoruz diyoruz yıllar önce bana bu
şekilde konuşan o kişiye günü göstermem
lazım Bu da çok ağır büyük söylemek
isteyip söyleyemediklerimiz de çok ağır
büyük acaba onları çıkartıp yerlerine
daha bize özgürlük alanı verecek neler
katabiliriz sanatla mı besleyebiliriz
Kendi
ve hobi alanlarımı genişleterek mi bazen
daha fazla susup daha az konuşup daha
çok dinleyerek Bence hepimizin de sınavı
Olabilir çünkü biz anlatmak için dünyaya
gelmiş varlıklarız Ben de bir hikaye
anlatıcı sayım Ben de hikayeler
anlatarak insanların şifalı
olabileceğini keşfettiğim günden beri
hem kendimi farklı hikayeleri
anlatıyorum Ve sürekli valisini kontrol
ediyorum ve gün geçtikçe daha iyi valiz
yapabildiğim e kanaat getirdim her gün
diyorum ki aslında dünyadaki bu görevimi
bir sonraki yolculuğa kadar Mümkün
Mertebe doğru geçirmeye doğru yaşamaya
başladım diyorum bu hissi bir şekilde
doğru valiz yaparak fazlalıkları mızı
atarak ve eksiklerimizi tamamlamak
konusunda cesaret göstererek
kavuşabilecek mi gördüm de bugün bunu
paylaşmak istedim
Evet dedim ya